this is great look familiar well that's
because I look rollcage
remember rollcage it's okay if you don't
mean it was an arcade racer that came
out back in 99 for the PlayStation in PC
where you could ride your car upside
down like that RC car you never got for
Christmas but for some reason rollcage
is a game what a bunch of fans around
the world maybe it was because the demo
was widely circulated maybe was because
of the unforgiving fast paced racing
perhaps it was the thumping techno Santa
but for some reason 17 years later yeah
I know of 17 the word roll cage still
gives many of us chills and that's why
grip exists originally launched as a
Kickstarter this spiritual successor to
the roll cage franchise has just
appeared on Steam early access twice
that 16 dollars it contains some Finnish
Devils some not so finished levels two
players split-screen and the usual rough
edges associated with an early access
release but roll cage fans around the
world only wants to know one thing its
grip as fun as crazy and full of sick
beats as roll cage I get to the details
in a second but first let's set the game
speak for itself
grep is a super-fast arcade racer where
you can flip your car overdrive on walls
and ceilings fire bombastic weaponry and
fly through the air across a number of
racetracks scattered across the universe
it has power-ups rubber banding and
winding tracks with multiple routes all
of this was some phat drum and bass
plays in the background grip is Mario
Kart just for people who prefer ecstasy
over mushrooms it's all about momentum
your car can accelerate incredibly fast
and reaches top speed relatively quickly
which means that most of the challenging
grip is ensuring that your car is at top
speed for as long as possible but that's
not going to be easy the maps and grip
are made up of winding tunnels ramps
jumps on even surfaces and tight
passageways even the slightest tip from
the terrain or an opponent can send you
spinning you'll spin a lot early on as
you get used to the track layouts and
the game's controls but little by little
it all starts to feel familiar and in a
couple of races time you'll be making
the choice to squeeze through tight gaps
to save you from having to pump those
brakes floss grip does a great job of
not punishing you too badly when you
inevitably crash and find yourself
turning in the wrong direction a pretty
quick reset button and optional catch-up
assist allow you to get back in the
action posthaste
what grip does well is make racing
challenging to use Mario Kart is a touch
point again most arcade races are
relatively simple the tracks are
straightforward the driving is easy and
most of the challenge comes from using
weaponry and power-ups effectively
honestly that's sort of what rollcage
was most of the levels were set on
tracks and while grip does have rockets
and mines and boosters oh my most of the
fun and challenge comes from wrestling
your car around it's twisting
unforgiving tracks so in many ways the
moment-to-moment racing and grip might
be even more engaging than its spiritual
predecessor there's some room for work
here it's an early access after all the
destruction for the original game isn't
as prevalent there's only a handful of
tracks for racing in a rather muted
deathmatch mode but the foundations are
here while there's nothing more telling
of its old-school roots than the fact
that it already has split-screen local
play as somebody who loved roll cage I
for one I'm really happy with how this
bad boy is turning out if you're
interested yourself
sixteen dollars is the asking price to
get early access to this lightning-fast
arcade racer did you play it yourself
let us know what you think in the
comments below